that's right folks the final installment
of the bridge The Hobbit the
Battle of the five armies The Hobbit the
Battle of five armies is the last Hobbit
movie in the Hobbit trilogy in the last
middle-earth movie we're probably gonna
get it barring a reboot of some sort of
I'm pretty sure this is it folks and in
this movie the dwarves have Erebor now
they have reached their goal but that's
not over Erebor is loaded with gold and
jewels and a bunch of everyone
wants it's pretty much prime real estate
now these five armies are gonna fight
for it you got dwarves you got elves you
got humans you got orcs you got more
orcs so that's what this movie is it's a
battle for real estate it's storage wars
with swords and it makes for a pretty
entertaining experience in that most of
the movie not all but most takes place
in this one spot it's just wave after
wave it's just battle after battle after
battle you're watching this movie you're
like man I wish there was more fighting
in it
comparatively you remember how people
were saying that the first Hobbit movie
was a bit too slow this is the reverse
of that this is all of the climax of a
movie with none of the slow you have all
the Peter Jackson middle-earth isms that
you've come to remember which pretty
much means it has really sweet
cinematography and a lot of CGI there's
a scene I remember seeing it in the
trailer it was the TV spot anyway
everyone was running and I was like
you're running on a green screen cuz it
looks like you're running on a green
screen the characters in this movie
that's right there's still BAM Silvo has
a couple of moments where you're like
that's why I love Martin Freeman as
Bilbo that's why he's great yeah and off
has more than a couple of moments I
liked his campaign a lot the whole
necromancer thing just that is the thing
that really stitches the Lord of the
Rings trilogy into The Hobbit trilogy
there's actually a scene with that
campaign I was like yeah that was pretty
cool there's no two ways around it he's
just like uh-huh
as the Lord of the Rings fan that was
pretty neat and for as much as you know
The Hobbit is a kids book and it was
made for kids for a couple of scenes
really like them that's not made for
kids this is just a bunch of dead bodies
in the water you're like whoa ulcer
potty
sleeve well Timmy that's where you those
are stiffs they're under your bed
because you don't eat your green beans
that's why and there are a couple of
moments in this movie where you like
feels
yeah it's touching not all of it
were
the romance between Evangeline Lilly and
dwarf number seven I liked in the last
movie with the assumption that it was
gonna lead to something in this movie
it's still in this movie but ultimately
you're like but it doesn't really hit
where it's supposed to so it makes you
reflect on desolation of smaug and you
feel like they wasted your time in that
movie I wish the romance in this movie
felt a little more relevant a little
more relatable a little more real and
this is the movie where you have all the
data you've now seen the entire Hobbit
trilogy now you can essentially like ah
I kind of see where it was taken from
two movies to three now like I said this
feels like the last act of a movie if
the Hobbit was two movies like it was
originally intended this entire movie of
the Battle of the five armies probably
would have been the second half of the
second movie you can't look at it you're
like okay you have the three movies the
first one was slow the second one was
pretty well balanced the third one was
all action if you slice it all in half
and shorten the beginning build-up in
the first Hobbit movie and shorten the
end battle which is the entire movie of
Battle of five armies you then put those
two movies together and you'd have a
pretty well-balanced - movie saga and
there was a part of me that thought
Smurfs of all the essentially Return of
the King is the final battle but it
still has the Frodo Sam element in the
Gollum element you have that going on
that kind of makes me feel more balanced
it feels like there's a collaboration
through the miles or kilometers because
it's middle-earth the mixture of heart
and action in Return of the King makes
it feel like it's more well-rounded
Battle of five armies is a real estate
battle that takes place in one place
with a bunch of badasses some emotional
moments that hit well a couple that kind
of fall flat some great action some
entertainment and the music when the
shit's going down just takes it from a
great action scene and just puts it over
the edge for you and it seamlessly
transitions into the Lord of the Rings
trilogy so now you have all of your
movies you have a six movie epic where
you can just sit down take an entire
24-hour block and watch your
middle-earth movies and that you can't
help but walk out of this movie and feel
that you're like oh it's it's over over
let's do that again I will certainly buy
this entertaining send-off to the Hobbit
movies and put it in my middle-earth
collection because I am saying The
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies is
worth buying on blu-ray that's right in
the world the cool Hobbit stuff I'm
about to send you to another video yeah
this is a shout out but is it cool one
check this out there's a youtuber she's
a violinist I don't know if you know who
she is her name's Taylor Davis I think
she's great just violin versions of
movie themes and video game themes which
is pretty sweet so she just did a video
for the new theme for the hop at the
Battle of five armies I'm gonna put a
link below check that
check out her video and then stick
around for her other videos and you'll
see why I think she's awesome if
Taylor's watching keep it up activate
that's what we did we just crashed the
internet didn't crash anything I'd like
to thank for that special day so the
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies and
The Hobbit movies in general what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]